the cardiac cycle is the sequence of
contraction and relaxation of the heart
chambers during a single
heartbeat the contraction of the heart
chambers is called
syy and relaxation of the heart chambers
is called
diast the cycle begins with both the
Atria and ventricles in
diast both atrio ventricular valves are
open while the pulmonary and aortic semi
lunar valves are
closed blood flows into the right atrium
through the superior and inferior
vinaa blood flows from the lungs into
the left atrium through the pulmonary
veins then blood moves from both Atria
into the ventricles through the open
atrioventricular
valves during atrial syy the Atria
contract and force any remaining atrial
blood into the
ventricles the ventricles are still in
diast allowing them to expand and
completely fill with
blood during ventricular
syy the ventricles
contract the
atrioventricular valves close preventing
backflow or
regurgitation of blood into the
Atria the pulmonary semi sem lunar valve
opens and the right ventricle expels
blood into the pulmonary arteries to the
lungs likewise the aortic semi lunar
valve opens and the left ventricle
expels blood into the aorta and out to
the rest of the
body after ventricular syy the cardiac
cycle begins again as both the Atria and
ventricles enter dios to allow the heart
to fill with
blood normally this cycle repeats 60 to
100 times a
minute the right side of the heart
produces pulmonary
circulation this is the movement of
deoxygenated blood from the body through
the right atrium and
ventricle out through the pulmonary
artery and to the
lungs blood oxygenated in the lungs
Alvi returns to the heart through the
pulmonary
veins the left side of the heart
produces systemic
circulation this is the movement of
oxygenated blood returning from the
lungs to the left atrium and
ventricle and out through the aorta to
be distributed to the rest of the
body